Elmo thanks for being here with a
Fandango calm we are we sell movie
tickets online you ever make yes I do
have two kids Finn and grace Finn and
grace no I've just made my wife we're
both kids
Trey and Susan
yes I know well we got
III actually I actually I got a friend
from my wife that looks like her I'm up
it that looks just like her we named it
Anne so if you want to say hi to ann in
her muppet that'd be great because she
she she loves her oh sorry sorry
her name's Anne so Elmo do you make it
to the movies a lot you go to the movies
and you like up and wall-e and all the
different elements noise Story 3 was
good
now now I heard a rumor they're making a
new Muppet movie are you are you in the
new puppet movie not in it he couldn't
make it
oh he was busy excellent well I also
heard you have some pretty good dance
moves sometimes you can do some good
stuff it's very good exercise excellent
and good so could you just say hi to
everyone Fandango say hi to everyone at
Fandango I don't know I just worked
there baby
thank you so much Elmo